ménard a perdu 46 ans annonce sa
candidature à l'investiture démocrate
dans l'intimité de son salon à el paso
au texas de tchaoudjo spurs il promet
une campagne positive entre autres sur
l'environnement et l'immigration v6
granby épreuve camping 2 6 3
mais toulouse a fait sensation en
novembre dernier alors que contre toute
attente il a failli battre le sénateur
républicain ted cruz au texas
il a fait campagne en mini fourgonnette
en rouli roulant sur les médias sociaux
et en improvisant ses discours des
milliers de personnes sont venues
l'entendre il a amassé 80 millions de
dollars en petits dons beto au look fait
déjà la une des grands magazines
il est en iowa aujourd'hui un passage
obligé pour tout candidat
il promet une campagne propre mais n'a
jamais hésité à s'attaquer dans notre
homme
et le président américain l'a déjà dense
amis le jeune texan s'ajoute aux 14
candidats démocrates en campagne sans
compter l'arrivée imminente de l'ancien
vice président joe biden en tête dans
les sondages est au moins six bateaux au
look réussira-t-il à répéter son exploit
de l'automne dernier alors qu'il a
failli ravir un siège de sénateur au
texas
la tâche s'annonce beaucoup plus
difficile sur la scène nationale les
observateurs s'entendent pour dire qu'il
devra ajouter un peu de substance à ses
discours
s'il souhaite rallier une majorité
d'américains ici christian latreille
radio-canada washington